hello everyone welcome to a gameplay
presentation of hitman my name is Travis
the community manager at IO Interactive
working on hitman and I'll be your guide
as we look at the showstopper level here
in Paris hitman is a creative stealth
action game where you perform contract
hits on powerful high-profile targets
all around the world and today we're in
Paris
our target is Victor Novikov he is a
very well known fashion brand owner and
a well known oligarch but in reality
he's actually the leader of a spy ring
called Iago now Viktor Nabokov is a very
well-protected man anywhere he goes he
brings all sorts of security with him
he's got a personal bodyguard who
follows him around he's got a local crew
that he's hired all sorts of security
guards to keep tabs on everything that's
happening at the Fashion Show and here
we are in Paris outside the Palais des
Valeska it's a huge environment for you
to explore before each and every single
mission in hitman you'll get a briefing
from your long-term handler Diana and be
able to choose exactly what you want to
take in to the level with you you can
choose a silenced pistol a knife or a
fully loaded assault rifle and extra
ammo maybe you want to take explosives
different poisons and lockpicks the
choice is entirely up to you
[Music]
as you play through the game depending
on what you do and how you play other
items will become available to you in
the loadout so that each time you go
into Paris you can change the way that
you play
the levels we've created are the biggest
ever in a hitman game and with that
comes the ambition to create locations
that feel like they're part of a real
world and they act and they react as you
would expect them to do just like that
news crew there of course they're not
happy that you've walked straight in
front of them but you had other options
you could have waited and listened to
what they had to say that might have
given you some information about your
target Nabokov what he's doing what he's
saying who he's meeting so as a player
hitman is very much about listening and
exploring the agency has arranged our
formal but incognito invitation to the
fashion show that takes place so we're
free to walk around the public areas of
the palace by day the palace is actually
an art gallery but tonight as there's a
special event going on that means that
the special restrictions that apply as
with any large-scale event there are
logistics areas with delivery trucks
staff carrying crates and boxes in and
out but of course those entrances are
guarded to the public so we can't go in
that way wearing our suit but we could
hop over the fence and sneak around if
we wanted to do that you can also climb
up drain pipes or go down into the
basement and in design terms we imagine
the palace like a Swiss cheese is full
of holes for you to climb through and
explore with no real dead ends wherever
you choose to go but as we've got an
invitation here we can just walk
straight in through the front door
welcome sir enjoy the show hey right
there coming down the stairs that's our
main target
that's Victor Novikov laughing in all
the applause as he always does
congressman a pleasure as always but
make sure to join dolly and I for a
drink later there's someone we would
like you to meet
now solo
he's what
if you'll excuse me congressman urgent
matter do enjoy rate
another cop's bodyguard has just
whispered something quite clearly
upsetting into his ear well let him get
on with that it's got lots of people to
talk to lots of things to take care of
that's a perfect excuse for us to show
you some of the other areas you can
explore and which you can start to get
you thinking about how you want to
approach your assassination we're
obviously showing you one way through
here but you can go anywhere in the
palace listening to short stories and
picking up information from everyone you
see and everything you hear
in hitman we've got more death traps per
square meter than ever before and this
gas lamp is just one example let's take
a look at a few more
[Music]
[Music]
you can see we've got the crown system
back for hit map on top of the crowd we
have over 300 fully simulated NPCs
populating the entire level they're all
active at the same time which means
anything you do on one side of the level
will have an impact on the other you can
trigger a fire alarm for instance that
and that will alert the entire building
as a comparison in the last hitman game
we had around 40 or 50 NPCs in the most
densely populated checkpoints so this is
a massive increase in any of those 300
characters or potential targets in
contracts mode which is also back from
absolutely
our focus today is purely unpicked
Novikov and it looks like he's backstage
again he's going about his business and
now it looks like he's arguing with the
lead designer of the fashion show look
don't be an [ __ ] Sebastian whether
you like it or not you are the star of
this show and you will act the part
oh no no I am NOT going up there this
line is a travesty you maybe do a
sellout
Viktor I'm not allowed in the backstage
area in my regular outfit so we'll need
a good disguise this stylist outfit is
perfect obviously as you have complete
freedom of approach there are numerous
ways to take out this stylist no matter
what approach you choose we always
recommend that you hide the body so it's
not to alert the guards
now that I'm disguised as a stylist I
have access to different parts of the
building again I'm relatively free to
walk around this area unless I do
something illegal or happen to get
spotted by someone who might be able to
see through my disguise there's a lot
happening here Saito is clearly stressed
out and you can definitely use that to
your advantage it's a perfect example to
show some of the fun you can have with
the game how you can get under some of
the characters skin and figure out
different ways of how the level will
play based on what you do you can create
your own rules and decide exactly what
you want to do whenever you're patient
and creative that's typically when
you'll get rewarded with these special
moments
[Music]
Nabokov is right here making a phone
call but he's with his bodyguard so we
can't get to him easily
we did notice a helicopter out in the
back garden that we want to get a better
look at so let's find a way out there
and we'll see where that takes us
[Music]
I've been in and out and still they
frisk me it's like hello
don't you recognize this little building
on your left can be used to stash a
weapon during your planning before
starting the mission right there you can
then pick it up at any time during the
mission and that adds an extra layer to
the options that you have instinct is
back for hitman but it's truly optional
it will highlight useful elements and
can be turned off entirely if that's
your style
we're going to skip ahead a little in
the interest of time up to that balcony
everywhere on the palace grounds that
you can see here you can explore
[Music]
but exactly how we got up to the first
floor and got this new waiter disguise
will stay a secret however there's still
plenty to show you in this playthrough
there's an entirely different atmosphere
on this floor with the staff preparing
food packing it into crates and moving
them up and down the stairs and that's a
great way for us to move weapons and
items up the stairs you just need to
hide a weapon there and the waiters will
carry it up for you through without
doing a security check first it's just
standard procedure we're offering the
guards that the stairs aren't familiar
with you though
so they're going to frisk you as long as
you don't carry weapons or anything
suspicious it might be okay to answer
[Music]
upon the second floor there's plenty
going on there's private quarters for
the people that live in the palace
during the daytime different corridors
and rooms different people on the phone
conversations going on guards patrolling
and there's even an additional target
you'll need to take out during a secret
auction going on in a lavishly decorated
room
[Music]
and a quick look at 47 hiding the gun
behind his back to keep it hidden from
the guards let's talk a little bit about
disguises right now were dressed as a
waiter and going into an area that we're
not allowed to be in so we'll need to
stay hidden from the guards disguises
are very very powerful and let you get
into different areas but they're not a
completely free pass
as we've mentioned before there were
some characters like the head of
security another cost bodyguard that
will be able to see through your
disguise no matter what it is there are
others that will be able to see through
individual disguises and we're calling
these characters in forces they've got
triangles above their head so let's take
this guy out and show you a bit more
about how that actually works
the yellow indicator and the guard in
the background appears because you're
near a dead body and in the crime scene
if you get spotted there NPCs will be
suspicious of you as we move out of that
crime scene
that yellow arrow has become white and
means you'll see through your disguise
so we still need to avoid them whenever
you change disguise the enforcers for
that disguise will also change you'll
always need to be on the lookout for
enforcers if you want to make the most
of your disguise
[Music]
up in this attic there were all sorts of
possibilities to create some nasty
surprises for our target today we don't
want to spoil too much of the setup so
let's just say that if you can figure it
out
you can make the huge light rigged above
the Fashion Show drop on lava cough as
he takes the stage maybe by himself
maybe not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
it's a lot of fun trying to figure these
situations out making a plan
manipulating and playing with the AI in
any way that you like that's what hitman
is all about will be showing you much
more before the game is out thank you
very much
you